t
penchés sur la question.
Anne-Louise Despatie.
♪ ♪ ♪
THOMAS TREMBLAY, élève de ent
- Je sais pas si vous avez déjà
eu un cours en ligne, surtout
des cours de  chimie, là,
ça peut être particulièrement
difficile de reste
- Les hauts et les bas de
l'école en temps de pandémiee p.
CORALIE HARDY-ROY, élève, 5e
secondaire, École Mgr Parent
- Très ent le fait
de moins voir mes amis puis
je stresp dans la vie.
CHAÏ HARVEY, élève, 5e
secondaire, Ecole Mgr Parent
s mal la seule chose
qui me motive.
e 2020. Une rentrée
masquée. Des bulles classes
l'école en ligne un jour sur
deux pour les plus grands.
Une vague de COVID,
suivie d'une autre.
Puis la vaccination pour
Des chercheurs en éducation
à l'une des Chaires UNESCO
de l'UQAM se sont penchés sur
l'année scolaire 2020-2021.
PATRICK CHARLAND, co-titulai
développement curriculaire,
- On voulait mesurer le bien
être, l'anxiété, l'inquiétude et
la motivation des élèves dans
certaines scolaires.
- Plus de 600 élèves et autant
d'enseignants de trois Centres
de serviondés.
Une fois à l'automne,
e fois vere fois vere fois vere.
- Est-ce que ça a fait en sorte
qu'ils sont restés à peu près
a nui à certains?
- Malgrésituatiosituatiosituatis
dernier, deux groupes sont
restés plus anxieux et moins
motivés que les autres :
et les finissants du secondaire.
- On le voit surtout aussi d
les entretiens qu'on a pu mener
avec le personnel scolaire, avec
les enseignants, les directions
d'école où, eux, ils ont observé
de travail social et
d'interventions, d
dépression qui ont dû abandonner
l'école.
sans équdaire ont écopé.
MYRIAM DESLAURIERS, élève, 5e
secondaire, Ecole Mgr Parent
- Les deux dernières années,
j'ai dûsur moi.sur moi.sur moi.n
organisation pour être capable
de suivre.
- Garder sa concentration
il y a d'autres distractions
à la maison, c'est difficil
et les notes baissent beaucoup.
- Pas facile de mesurer les
apprentissages des élèves,
qu'il n'y a pas eu d'épreuves
ministérielles et seulement deux
- Alors ici, on a le ski de fond
qu'on appelle clas
- Cette enseignante en sciences
constate que parents et élèves
de la réussite scolaire.
ISABELLE BOUCHARD
enseignante; science secondaire
- Au niveau du travail des
l'essentiel de ce qu'ils ont
à appretenant, latenant, latenaa
réception, ca, j'ai des gros
doutes. Les élèves qui ont le
vraiment... j'ai le feeling
s perd davantage.
JONATHAN BLUTEAU psychoéducateur
- On peut aussi se dire que
les enfa adolescen adolescen ads
ont fait d'autres types
d'apprentissage. L'apprentissage
ça ne se fait par un examen et
examen.
- L'arrêt scolaire du début de
la pandémie aura pour un certain
sait pas pour combien d'années.
voquait pour 5, 6 ans.
- On espère que les études
actuelles permettront de biencis
qui auront le plus souffert de
ce parcours en denposer qu'il va
y avoir une perte d'acquis.On ne
que c'est une génération
sacrifiér que ca ne
touche pas seulement que notre
système scolaire.
- Je pense qu'on a appris pas
n manque peut-
être de pratique. Exemple,
en sciences, les laboratoire
- En arrivant au cégep, il vacen
n'aura pas, mais qui vont pas
être trop diffici
- Ces élèves croient aussicommen
dernier, de leur b
Une autre raison pour eux d'être
plus optimistes.